the queen again sliding across one
square that Queen just can't decide
where it wants to be but the black king
is going to become a huge Target and
okay The Bishop's stepping back what's
stopping white from taking that point
nothing nothing David okay he takes
another Point first that doesn't matter
it doesn't change the uh scheme of
things seeing he knows he's in trouble
he's shaking his head there fortunately
it is ding that is suffering because he
just has a over 30 seconds on the clock
wow push the pawn forward at the right
time yeah white lining up the queen with
the black king I'd also be tempted to
jump in with my knight I miss it I'm
just spoiled for children sexualize the
White Queen yeah magnus's style all over
and okay black trying to hold things
together with the black queen but the
black queen looks overworked she's
protecting at night she's protecting a
bishop it feels like just one move will
break the defenses now if Magnus is
accurate he jumps in with the knights
and ding Retreats the night there's
nothing for it and uh what
and uh wow Checkmate is coming on the
board